hi this is Paul and today I'm having a
conversation with Jonathan pooja he
probably needs no introduction to anyone
who's subscribed to my channel and I a
couple of weeks ago I sent Jonathan an
email I said with with all the Sam
Harris talk I thought it might be fun if
if we'd do a conversation both Jonathan
and I have been recently doing a lot of
videos that have kind of been downstream
from this talk and so Jonathan I really
appreciate your willingness to have a
conversation today yeah it's great to
it's great to talk to you again we're
doing this once in a while it's nice and
and yeah I've really been appreciating
your kind of constant are you taking it
on so intensely this whole discussion
and in talking with everybody and
looking at everything so so you know
although I don't watch every video
because I think it's like a video out
every single day which is really intense
but uh but once in a while a drop in and
then I you know I'll try to kind of
follow where you are so it's been fun to
do that well I appreciate it and I've
watched your last two existence in Santa
Clause videos and and that's kind you
know it's it's been interesting to me
how we're both kind of chewing on this
stuff and you know I was thinking this
morning thinking about this how you know
myself as a pastor my vocation is to try
to communicate God who cannot be
contained by our language in in verbal
form and of course in in Christian
theology that the Bible is the Word of
God and this is this is special
revelation and I was thinking about your
vocation not just as in Protestant talk
you know a Christian artist but an icon
Carver and I thought that might be an
interesting place to begin because you
know I've heard both of us trying to
communicate to an audience within our
cultural context that says well if God
isn't an object then God isn't and so I
guess I kind of wanted to ask you a
question as as an icon Carver how does
this work for you and I saw you I
thought really I thought I saw you
communicating about principalities and
powers
and using that as an avenue to talk
about how God exists the ontology of God
how God is real and so I wanted to you
know pick your brain on this a little
bit more so how is an icon carver does
this does this connect with you well I
think I first of all I think that one of
the things that I have maybe not as an
icon maybe yes as an icon cover or
someone who views things in terms of
images is I tend to view I tend to
understand analogy pretty well I think I
tend to see the world with analogies and
so because of that I can understand
I think the manner in which God both
transcends all representation but then
also fills the entire world with his
presence and so that's been really the
double move that I've been trying to get
people to see you know we see that in in
the the work of dionysius the areopagite
and and and also in pretty much all of
mystical Christianity this notion that
God is beyond all you know all being you
know all representation all word all
language everything there's no manner in
which we can fully encompass God but
that also and at the same time and
almost in a certain manner because of
that God fills the entire in the
entirety of all creation fills
everything and and and makes everything
coherent in and hold together and so
those two realities have to kind of
always be held up at the same time you
know because you get an apathetic move
which is this move of saying you can't
represent God and you see that now in a
lot in the modern world you see it all
the time people who say things like we
can't represent reality but their
conclusion is that therefore everything
is arbitrary right all our constructions
are arbitrary all our are the way that
we organize society all these things
your values all of it's all arbitrary
because we can't represent reality but
the but there and and it brings up a
certain type of nihilism I think that I
think that for example existentialism
has that problem and a lot of
post-modernism has that problem but the
right move is to do both is to say yes
we can't there's an apple Phatak move
where
the world even the world itself is
beyond our capacity to fully encompass
it God definitely is beyond our capacity
to encompass his his being or you know
his over being or you know his essence
but like at the same time we can see
these sparks of God this this the
presence of God in everything and so in
terms of art the theology of the icon is
very specific about this that we cannot
represent God and that's really
important that's one of the things that
people tend to not understand about
icons is that we don't represent God um
at least we're not supposed to if there
are aberrations you know like like all
human activity there are aberrations
which happen but in the traditional icon
for example up to let's say about the 14
13 14th century you actually don't even
see images of God the Father at all in
Christian art we only represent Christ
even when we represent the creation of
the world even when we represent you
know the Last Judgement all these images
it's always Christ that is represented
because the image of God appears through
Christ and then ultimately through man
as being the image of God and so that is
the way that we can do that double move
where we say sometimes they'll represent
the divine as just these kind of empty
circles at the top of an image you like
very abstract image or just a hand or
something which which is just kind of
suggests that there's something beyond
and you can't represent the actual face
of the of God in his essence or God the
Father even and so it's that double move
that that that is there in that
president I think preserve the mystery
but then also shows us how the world
lays itself out out of that mystery you
know as I as I hear you talking on you
know you mentioned how there is a there
is a tendency in the there's a tendency
towards Skepta there's a deep set
skepticism in our current culture and
you know you know I've both listened to
a fair amount of Don Hoffman and those
conversations are very interesting in
terms of Don Hoffman coming at this from
from a Darwinian perspective and a
scientific perspective that suggests
that our limited
capacity to just engage common reality
to just apprehend it you know I I saw I
have that my daughter took in this this
kitten this feral kitten and so and I've
got this old dog that's almost blind and
so the dog is trying to chase this
kitten and the kitten just jumps up on a
chair and the dog keeps sniffing around
and can't find it and I'm watching this
and I'm thinking about all the youtubes
I'm making and I'm thinking in many ways
this is a picture of us that we have we
have limited capacity and so when I
think about God you know in terms of CS
Lewis writing himself into the story I
think you know for example the burning
bush story where there's a physical
representation there's it's a it's a
miraculous physical representation but
then there's also a verbal
representation and in fact that the name
is given I am what I am or I will be
what I will be and and and so you know
to think that this these are the tools
God uses with Moses to introduce himself
to a people that has forgotten him hmm
and and I think about Jordan Peterson's
use of of Mythology and I look at the
number of people that are communicating
with me and saying things like you know
I now I I don't not quite sure what God
is but I want to believe in a God and I
I want to go down that path of seeking
and and I think so then I think isn't
this interesting how so many modernistic
rationalistic apologists have been
banging on a door a certain way getting
zero results and this guy who's
Christian confession is complicated at
best suddenly moves the ball mm-hmm and
and then I look at Anna and then of
course you came into the picture and I
had seen a number of other people who
were showing interest in
Christian traditions that were far more
symbolic than let's say contemporary
Protestant apologists and watching that
happen
and and thinking this this to me
obviously as a believer and as a pastor
says to me well I think this is I think
this is a movement of God's Spirit as a
Calvinist you know it's well God's you
know God moves history this is not we
are not in control of history God moves
history and this is this is a means by
which God is using to to do the work
he's always done which is call call the
rebellious people to himself and it's
interesting how have we reached the end
of this descriptive phase of our
language and in a sense now
perhaps as we've exhausted this means
people don't know it consciously but
intuitively begin to imagine you know
and then suddenly Jordan Peterson
appears who had been talking about this
stuff for a long time suddenly the man
in the moment come together and bang off
it goes yeah it definitely seems it's
hard not to see and almost you know to
use the word Providence in the sense
that it seems like Jordan just fell into
this place and and he's he's kind of
he's taking up a space of something that
was all building up for to happen and I
think that we're watching it unfurl as
it as it happens and it's pretty it's
pretty impressive to to watch but I
think you're right when you talk about
this notion of reaching the end of the
purely descriptive the problem which
happens and I think post-modernism plays
a role in that as well to a certain
extent because one of the things that
post-modernism was able to show is that
the the purely descriptive rationalistic
way of looking at the world it ignores
language it ignores it ignores language
as if language is just doesn't exist but
once you start to see how the structures
of language and also how when you try to
apply language to itself you know and
the same thing happens when you try to
now apply the tools of rationality to
consciousness
whoa some weird things start to happen
because all
son you realize that consciousness you
even even even most of the most of like
the New Atheists
Sam is the one who's kind of standing
apart but I I don't think he totally
fully understands the let's say the the
ramifications of his move is that they
take consciousness for granted they take
the fact that here we are looking at the
world for granted and that that's
actually not part of the universe okay
so so we're we're just this is blind
like there's no there's no almost as if
there's no looker and there's just this
universe but once you start to notice
the looker and then you strive to pull
out and see the looker looking at the
universe then that's what I've been
arguing is that all of a sudden all the
hierarchy sets itself up again it's
inevitable because consciousness acts as
this fulcrum which creates a hierarchy
of attention a hierarchy of being a
hierarchy of virtue a hierarchy of value
all these things happen as soon as
consciousness reenters into the picture
and so the sides of consciousness and
people like Don Hoffman are very
fascinating to pay attention to because
even though they might they might be
doing it unwittingly they're they're
they're going I think to flip things in
a certain direction in which we're going
to be surprised very soon that it will
be possible I think it's already
possible to say things like angels and
demons without people freaking out and
thinking that you're talking about you
know like multi-dimensional beings or or
some kind of basically space aliens with
I always think like most modern people
think that aliens are that angels are
space aliens you know Marvel Comics type
you know Thor that's what they think but
if you start to understand this
hierarchy of consciousness and how they
stack up then it doesn't become that
weird anymore to talk about these things
oh we'll talk more about that because
you know so you know whatever thing I
was pursuing was Sam Harris is talking
about his his daughter's fascination
with superheroes yeah and I found that
extremely interesting because as both of
you you use Santa Claus I used Mickey
Mouse
Mickey Mouse is real enough to continue
to forestall you know copyright
legislation in the United States I mean
Mickey Mouse is had second
world yeah that's right and and so but
no I think we preserve his own identity
exactly what the Chinese to get ahold of
them it's right and to do to Mickey what
what they've done for anyway yeah so so
say you know because I I think when I
think when it when I come to this
ontology when I come to this ontology
part of the conversation what always
stands out to me is it's in a sense
Jordan Peterson talking to the the the
queer folks at the at the protest and
say well I kind of wonder about your
motivations because I at heart what I
think people have an instinctive fear
that we are not alone and and so you
hear that both in terms of aliens but
the the idea that there is a you know if
a tsunami comes and and wipes out a
village and everyone says well that's
just a force of nature it's impersonal
people seem to be able to accept that
better than to say well there is a there
is a sentient conscious force being God
in the universe that willed this to
happen
somehow when personality gets involved
all of our motivations get redirected
and so when you talk about you know
angels and space aliens they say a
little bit more about that in terms of
how you think how they work in our
imaginary right yeah well yeah sadly I
don't think right now they work in the
right manner III think that we it comes
with the same problem of taking
consciousness for granted you know
people are offended at the idea of
speaking of God I mean like I said God
transcends personhood that is definite
but personhood is part of God that is
there is you know the notion that God is
three persons is extremely important in
terms of understanding what you know
what a person is and and and also like I
said because we take consciousness for
granted
somehow we're bothered by the fact that
consciousness exists it's so funny
people always you know people aren't
offended by the idea that sometimes you
hear people say like I
but I believe that God is more or if
there is a God that is more like a like
a force you know like a kind of
impersonal thing and you think so well
so why why why does it bother you why
does consciousness bother you why does
why does why do you think that
intentionality is is doesn't exist that
it's a freak thing that exists only in
in human beings for some reason you know
it's like there are patterns there there
patterns of being and that's what that's
what personalities are right they're
patterns of being there they're patterns
that are coherent and they're cohered in
a way that they manifest the purpose and
so that's intentionality and within us
we have several little smaller beings we
also have all these personalities inside
us that have their own little coherences
not so much sometimes and and so I don't
know why that's so weird to think
because we're we're not that obviously
one coherent conscious being that we're
where we are but constituted with all
these little coat
you know conscious consciousnesses why
is it so weird to think that that would
scale up I don't understand why it's
weird and so III am that's why for me
it's almost like a mystery when I listen
to people it's all I always think it's
just because you don't understand
what is consciousness you also do you
don't understand what constitutes of
being how a being is not obvious in
terms of scientific analysis that there
really has to be something which pulls
it together and so and so to me the once
we start to see that then angels the
idea of angels are they just don't
there's not a they're not a big deal
anymore like they're they're as and the
idea of demons - I mean to me demons are
just principalities which are not united
in this coherent hierarchy and that's
how the Church Fathers present them
anyways you know so you have you have
some some usually it's aligned with a
passion and makes sense because that's
what it happens in us you know you have
a person you have a pattern inside you
you know and this pattern that kind of
runs and it has its own coherence but
what
does it's it's pulling you away from
your central core so it's making you you
know resent something it's making you
hate your children it's making you like
whatever whatever pattern that is there
and you're fighting against it you're
trying to bring it in and sometimes you
can't and it kind of pulls you um to me
that's just it's a it's a demon it's a
it's it's it's a it's a little demon
that is pulling you and if you read like
the Mystics they talk about demons that
you're full of demons or that they're
demons are constantly either they say
you're full of demons or they'll say
things like they're demons riding on you
like you have demons riding on your back
like all these demons that are riding on
you and I think it's just an imagistic
way of saying that you have these these
these patterns which are pulling you
into death so they're that are that are
ripping you apart that are decomposing
you and so you need to bring it together
and so there are cosmic I think there
are cosmic demons in in the city you
could have you have certain patterns of
behavior let's say let's say in a city
you'll have a pattern of behavior which
is jaywalking where everybody jaywalks
I remember I remember there was a story
about Giuliani about how everybody New
York was jaywalking and Giuliani
understood that that pattern of behavior
what it looked like it was a detail but
it was actually manifesting a much
deeper reality which is that there was
no social cohesion in New York City and
so he said I'm going to exorcise this
demon and and once it's exorcised it's
actually going to help coagulate the
'sydney bring it together so that it has
more cohesion and so he went after
jaywalkers and just gave dick dick and
first people were going crazy like what
is he doing why is he attacking
jaywalkers but he kind of understood
that we need to exercise these little
demons so that the being can can now
come together and so that little pattern
of behavior it was that everybody was
doing it it wasn't like people were
talking to each other and say oh are you
jaywalking oh no I
are you jaywalking yeah I jaywalking no
nobody does it just was it was like this
implicit pattern of behavior in the city
I mean it could be littering it could be
all kinds of things would you let it go
too far then it's really hard to to
bring it back like one let's say once a
Civic pattern starts to manifest
in a city where it's okay to break
people's windows let's say all of a
sudden it becomes okay to break people's
windows it's really hard to to come back
from that you know and then things can
degenerate into into chaos I mean I
lived in in cities in Africa where the
the social fabric had been so destroyed
by war and all kinds of crazy events
that it was almost impossible to bring
it back because everybody had these all
these little demons were kind of pulling
the city into all these directions and
it was it was nearly impossible to to
bring it back I really liked so one of
the things that I've done with with
trying to figure out Peterson and Harris
was I talked about God aspect one in God
aspect two and I think your your
Giuliani jaywalking example is a
terrific example of let's say God aspect
one and and that even Brett Weinstein
and could could say okay that's that
that use of God I can get into that use
of demon I can live with I think you
know and I I often in terms of trying to
communicate this concept and Pauline
theology about principalities and powers
I often will talk about those types of
things because I think highly
secularized people can can understand
that except that that doesn't make them
nervous the the representation tation of
demon also has within it a personal
agency thing and an example of this
might be let's say and I often use the
example of a marriage a marriage is not
a physical thing I'd say well there's a
there's a document that says we're
married well that's a representation
there's a wedding ring well that's a
representation no one will deny no one
who is actually in a marriage will deny
that that marriage is a loser II know
marriage is very real marriage governs
behavior marriage marriage a marriage
has a high degree of ontology that in
fact governs generations of persons and
and deeply forms for good or for ill
children and I needed to and people's I
mean marriage is an enormous leap our
fulfill some times feel like it has
agency
and I think but but we wouldn't say most
of us don't name our marriages you know
we just it's just the marriage Angels &
Demons have names
yeah implicit in the in the Fallen Angel
backstory of demons as characters in the
Bible I mean these are these are centers
of agency and so when I think about the
talk about angels and demons and
especially God that this the god aspect
number two that Sam Harris I mean Jordan
Peterson is going through his axioms and
and and sam harris stops them and says I
want to know about the God who doesn't
want me to masturbate and you know a God
who has a locus of agency who who also
has power unlike let's say the power
that your marriage has to shape your
behavior because nothing as we try to
represent what a marriage is in our mind
it's it's something similar to the
culture of jaywalking at Giuliani brakes
and the demon of jaywalking that that
Juliana uses to exercise a certain
degree of chaos from New York City when
I visited New York City and in 2006 I
hadn't been there since the 80s or the
70s where I grew up I grew up just
outside of it and it was like what is
this place you know when where's where's
all the dirt where's the you know where
all these young beautiful white people
come from a this is a New York City and
and so you know you can see that in a
city and I thought you represented that
well but there's this other aspect of
number two which is really the one that
I think has the celebrity atheists and
that community spooked and and reactive
- yeah well okay so I think that once
again the problem arises with again the
the difficulty of understanding being
and understanding consciousness again
it's the same problem let me give you an
example within yourself right do you
think that those demons I say those
those little
patterns do you don't you do you think
they don't have agency of course they
have agency right they they they have
they they know what they want right they
know exactly what they want and you can
you can if you're sensitive if you're a
bit if you're a little bit attentive you
can see that you're actually talking to
them that you can you can talk to your
demons you know and you can you make
deals with your demons all the time
right
imagine a smoker right so the smoker
what the demon wants is for that person
to pretty much chain smoke all the time
that's what the demon wants right
and so then you make a deal with the
demon you say okay I'm I'm gonna smoke
you know like three cigarettes a day or
like whatever amount that you decide
that you're gonna smoke when you're
doing that you're you're making you're
actually you're you're you're
negotiating with your demon you know and
you're you know that if you just let it
go if you just let that even pull you
out like you would be smoking all the
time or you if you're if it's drinking
or whatever whatever desire if it's you
just eating you could just eat all the
time because that's that pulling you but
you make a deal you're like okay no I'm
going to I'm going to I'm going to
negotiate with this and so I think that
it's the same it's the same it's kind of
the same thing going up I think that
that agency is just a pattern of is a
pattern of being the problem with with a
problem with with the manner in which we
understand freedom is that we understand
freedom as the capacity to do whatever
you want and and I think that that's
really a misunderstanding of freedom
freedom freedom is the freedom is the is
the capacity to act from within your own
self and not not be fully let's say
determined by your outer circumstance
okay and so that's what agency is so
that's what I add that's what I think
freedom and agency are and so if that's
what freedom and agency are then you can
understand that a pattern has its own
energy like it has its own will in its
own thing and so it
it has the capacity to act to act and
then also because patterns are made of
smaller patterns it also has the
capacity to manage those smaller
patterns and then to not to let
themselves get pulled in one direction
or the other so there is this that
what's what I think it's that's kind of
what I think agency is and so to me the
idea that you can pray to that you can
pray to a to like the Angel of a city
it's like that's what you're doing when
you if you write a letter of complaint
to the City Council like who's the city
councilor who's the city like you write
a letter of complaint to the city like
who are you writing it to you're not
riding it to anybody you're writing it
to the city and so you're actually
engaging you're you're praying to the
city you're asking the city to to do
something for you and we you know and it
can answer does it mean it's going to
answer it might not answer might answer
in a way you don't like it to answer but
it but it can't answer and so to me it's
that's just kind of how that's how it it
it works and so the idea that you pray
to God or that you pray to to other
beings that it vir there be to the
pastor you pray to the pastor you ask
the pastor that you to - I mean people
use the word I know I know it's like
it's not the word pray just means to ask
for something it's not English issue I
know because a Spanish and in in Greek
and other languages they're the words
our commonality but you say it in
English I I just I just know a lot of
Protestants and my oh you don't but you
do all the time right you ask someone to
help you change your tire you ask you
know so you're so you're constantly
praying and and and beings answer your
prayer and so to me the idea that you
can pray to to higher beings you can ask
for for things is three is just not a
big deal and this the fact that you can
pray to God to me is that you can pray
said you can address your prayer to the
highest let's say I think is not a
problem I do think this this is where
maybe you you will totally disagree with
me but I do think that often because the
word God also is so wide I think that
often once
one prays to God to ask God for some
very petty thing I think usually they're
not really praying to God they're
actually praying to something that's
lower they just don't they just don't
totally know you know it's like so
that's that's maybe of the more kind of
the moral it's a idea of a Catholic
person who would ask you know some saint
to find a parking place for them or
something like that that's really a very
kind of petty you know very kind of
petty low thing but it doesn't mean that
it's not it's not also possible it we
don't understand the we people don't
understand like again it's always taking
consciousness for granted it's it's not
understanding the manner in which
consciousness which language which logos
participates and how the world lays
itself out you know it does participate
in how the world ladies itself out
whether you know it to what extent it
does at what's the limit of that is not
is not that is not that easy to
determine I think I might be pushing you
a little bit too far though I trust me
you you don't people people when they
push me think I get upset but I know no
I've never seen you get upset it's so
there's just so many interesting there's
just you know there's so many
interesting things that popped in as you
were answering one of the things is
obviously the connection between between
this experience of freedom that we have
this experience of choice this
experience me one of the things when you
know going back earlier in the
conversation when we're talking about
God being beyond being one of the you
know one of the theological
conversations that then crops up is is
that within let's say a distinction
between say a Christian conception of
the world and let's say a Hindu
conception of the world is in the
Christian conception there is there is
God and not God and it is it is it is
the existence of not God
that is that is basically the and that
hind'
a Hindu istic conception to the degree
that I understand it lacks yeah
wait what what's happening okay but at
least in the Orthodox tradition we do
have this notion of the divine energies
which is which is extremely important in
in grace in the Orthodox tradition this
notion of grace is seen as God Himself
that grace is God and so the the grace
which underlies the world which is at
the root of all manifestation is are
these divine energies that is these that
we use the word the word energies
obviously is too mad that we still use
that word because it's so ruined wills
the will or the Wills of God are
underlying all of phenomena and they can
actually transfigure phenomena so that
eschatologically right in the totality
of all things God actually fills all
things so it's not to say that no it's
not we usually make the distant
distinction at least an Orthodox
theology between essence like the divine
essence we are not we don't share God's
divine essence but we participate in God
through participation we we become God's
through participation
and that's a way that's a way to create
that that that absolute separation like
you said between let's say the the
ultimate yeah infinite and manifestation
but if there's there's also this
eschatological reality which is that all
things are called you know ultimately to
be transfigured and full of of God and
to to kind of enter into God and
participate in God's God's I would say
being I wouldn't I use the word being
here in the sense that the way that God
the way that God out pours into into
everything but not in his essence that's
kind of the way that
but I agree that it does it is different
from the kind of emanation Asteria that
that you see in Gnosticism and you see
also in Hinduism and the problem with
emanation is the emanation is series is
that because they they they they have
this notion of emanation they almost
necessarily have to diminishing so they
have to see as you move down let's say
the hierarchy of manifestation you have
to see it almost as if it becomes evil
in itself right and so that's why the
Gnostics will see the material world as
being evil because because of this
emanation ISM then it's like the things
that are lower on the hierarchy actually
have to be evil the let's say the great
innovation or the great let's a
realization of Christianity is that this
separation between God and creation is
what makes everything good is what makes
everything good in its in its higher
let's say in the in the in the manner in
which it points to God right it makes it
good and so and so you even at the even
the humblest thing that we do not have
in Christianity the idea that someone
who is poor is is is BA is cursed by by
de facto you know is is somehow lesser
is somehow of less containing less of
that that oomph that kind of ontological
you know um we don't believe that we
believe that all things participate in
can participate in God and can be
transfigured no matter where they are on
that kind of social hierarchy and that's
a big difference it's a I think it's a
huge difference alright I think that's
right in I don't know I mean part of the
poverty of of living in the West has has
been not an insufficient education in
and I'm sure your Orthodox theology is
is at least as at least as diverse and
broad as as the Western tradition
how does hell then how does hell then
function in the system in
orthodoxy there there are different
there are different obviously there's
different theories there's different
ways to look at it I mean sometimes hell
is definitely represented as a kind of
eternal like eternal punishment that
kind of manner in which it is but the
most popular I would say at least in my
circles at least in the circles of
people I read and the people that I that
I engage with the most popular manner in
which we understand hell is that the
fire of hell is the fire of Pentecost
those two fires are the same and so the
the the hell is the is the fullness of
the presence of God in all things that's
what hell is the difference is that for
those who who have opened themselves up
right for those who have opened
themselves up to the grace of God then
that grace becomes transfigures whereas
for those who have clothed themselves
office has attached himself to their
resentments to their passions to the to
those things that decompose them then
that fire burns them I always used the
example of I would use the example of
how if I you know if I do something
horrible to you you know I I do
something really really despicable to
you and I and I do it you know with all
the spite that I can do it with and your
answer to me is this pure love just pure
unadulterated love and forgiveness and
openness now when I encounter that I can
do two things right I can repent and
kind of enter into your love and be
transformed by it or I can just close
myself off even more and then that love
that you're showing to me becomes it
burns me right it's fine burning coals
holes on my head like Paul st. Paul says
and so that's really the man the man and
which is usually talked about so that
also that is this kind of if you look at
the eschatological reality like a total
reality it represents it represents all
that in us right now even all that in us
right now that is resisting to be
transformed by grace
it's burned by the presence of God it
that's what burns us even our guilt all
that stuff inside us it's actually God
it's actually the love of God that is
burning us and so that's really the way
that it's it's a presented and then
there is there is in your representation
of it they're a fairly strong necessity
of agency there because there is there
is a center there is an agent with
choice who is who's deciding do I do I
give up
you know CS Lewis lay down your arms do
I do I give up my hostility and my
bitterness and my resentment or you know
do I give that up and open myself up to
this love and therefore accepting and
you know receiving the embrace of this
of this other agent of this other you
know of this other agent who's whose
will and capacity and resources are far
beyond mine who yet in its even in a
sense an expression of his mercy that he
allows my agency to to exist apart from
his own mm-hm
you know it struck me so of course
Peterson with with the David fuller
conversation you know I wanted to know I
I don't know if he I don't we were
discussing at our meetup last night if
my if my characterization of some of
what I hear from him as stoicism
triggered him a little bit but I love
maybe all having a chance to ask him
that sometime but then he you know
what's on if I'd been listening I'd
notes the City of God on the hill which
really made me laugh yeah but his
description of that of maximal
responsibility when I heard that
description I thought much more of
something in terms of what you just
described because at this point you know
people will often say well what kind of
a God would what kind of a God would
seeing him kill me and when people say
that I think you don't we could use the
consciousness language you don't really
understand what what it's like to be in
the presence of a being
that changes how you look at yourself
you know we we have this in in
foundational relationships with let's
say parents or authority figures or or
people that we wish to emulate and we
desire to be like you know you turn that
but you turn that all the way up to
infinite in the presence of God and the
the the light and clarity of his being
exposes all of our insufficiencies which
then which then puts us in a place where
where we now have an existential crisis
in terms of our identity and our agency
in every aspect of our being and so when
I thought of okay you drag that cross up
the hill and and now you're forced to
you're forced to face you're forced to
be accountable for all of the all of
your use of agency in your life when I
heard that I thought while you're
talking Judgment Day you're talking
standing in the presence of God and all
that that would mean and and I would
think if if a good number of people know
that that's what awaits them at the top
of the hill they're gonna stay in the
basement play video games
that's Alerus know I but I think yeah I
think they return the window when Jordan
using the term City of God I also was
surprised because I never heard him use
it before but then when I you sent me
text from maps of meaning which which
talks about the City of God and his
description of it well then the
description that he talks about I have
seen him talk about it this notion of of
of this city which is you know that is
the the representation of order but
order in a manner which is also open or
let's say looking out towards chaos and
not being completely secluded but at the
same time that is together and looking
towards truth and looking towards
responsibility like you talk like you
talked about and so yeah I think that
for sure it there is something and it's
also there's something there is somebody
got a stoic about about that in the in
the manner that one of the things that
seems to be missing is this
is the glory let's say the participation
in the glory and and that is something
that at least if you look at the
mystical tradition and you look at this
transformative tradition of what it
means to be Christian that you're meant
to become yes to do that exactly what he
said to to take your cross to bear
responsibility you know there's all this
tradition also even in these all these
Orthodox stories about how people will
take upon themselves even the you know
the fault of others you know there's
there's all these these wild tradition I
was looking at at one pretty crazy
tradition today about I forget I think I
I'm it's horribly I don't remember name
it was some Russian aristocrat who who
hadn't heard that one of the priests in
her City was having an affair with a
prostitute and so she went straight to
his house into his room enter the room
took the prostitute kicked her out of
the room and then got on her knees and
says father I need to confess my sins I
was like you know it's like that oh my
goodness you know hey Jake she knows
exactly what's true and she goes to the
end of it and then she takes his back on
herself and says and supposedly then the
priest totally got converted and did you
see that st. Francis does that - there's
there stories of st. Francis doing that
- where where you know someone asks them
what about this priest who's living with
a woman and he kind of says I don't I
don't even deserve to kiss this man's
feet and he gets on his knees and he
kisses the priests feet in the breeze
like no don't do that if you know you're
killing me by doing that and so there's
this this crazy transformation and so I
think that that that there's there's
something really powerful that but then
I think what's missing is also then this
this glory that you find in the lives of
the Saints this is also this this sum
this joy right this joy that comes the
surprise of joy that kind of comes in
and and fills the person in kind of
indescribable joy or in a kind of the
Orthodox we often talk about
I feel sadness like this strange mix of
joy but also an awareness of all the
suffering and all the difficulties of
the world at the same time those two
things join together um so so yeah so I
think that that's maybe what's what's
what's missing well it's it's you know
even if you're let's take the
representation of dragging something up
a hill someone in my meet up last night
brought up Sisyphus of course because
you bring it up the hill and then it
goes back down and and that isn't there
is you know the reason you know with all
of Jordans stuff about mapping meaning
and all this I mean the reason that
dragging that thing that cross up the
hill gives the experience of meaning is
is obviously because there's meaning
built into into the world in which you
are acting and and that when you get to
the top of the hill there is joy there's
you know there's joy the Kotchman of
accomplishment and peterson himself
talks about you know the the nazis you
know making people take sacks back and
forth in order to completely destroy
meaning so it's i I also I also thought
you know not only was there Judgment Day
at the top of the hill and I and a
number of people mentioned joy but you
know one of the things that I'm planning
on that then sent me to Plato and
Agustin because you know person as a
city and that then brought me back to
your principality in a sense what
Giuliani does by fining by finding
jaywalkers is make it the city of
Giuliani but Giuliani
hate to see has done with himself now I
know you had to bring up Giuliani had
his moment he had his moment that's
right so so here's a question for you
now myself as a minister people will
listen to me and say well pastor it's
your job to try to make people
Christians why do you want people to
believe in God
mm hmm why do I want people to be
funny I don't I don't see it I don't see
it that way like I don't I think that
the idea that people don't believe or
believe in God to me is so kind of
irrelevant because I I think that not
irrelevant like it's kind of horrible
that I'm saying that people be like what
is he talking about it's just that I
don't know what you mean like I also
don't know what you mean when you say
that I I that they that they believe in
God to me it has to be more than just
believing God that it has to be an
entering on to a path right and entering
on to a path of life and that's what
matters right what is it that it says
even in in Scripture that the devil
believes so you know Satan believes in
God and he and he trembles and so it's
not just about believing in God but
really entering on that path um and so I
think that I think that I do believe
that that path of coming together of
turning together of of celebrating the
right thing of praising the right thing
of moving towards the right thing I see
it as the solution to our personal
problems to our family problems to the
community's problems i I see it
basically as the way in which things
will come together and and have purpose
and meaning and not be constantly
decomposing and so to me it's that's
what that's why that's what I my whole
purpose is that is to to help people see
the coherence and the beauty and the
power of this path which is that which
is the the you know the Christian the
Christian path and and so it's more so
it's more to me than then just believing
in God that's why I almost never all
right sometimes I do but I rarely talk
about God because I don't know you know
it's like I'd rather kind of try to show
you the transformational aspect of
Christianity try to show you how
transforms the world and hopefully then
it'll give you a glimpse of this divine
mystery but for it's very difficult for
me to talk directly about God I tend to
to not want to do that too much in some
of the Q&A is people are always asking
me any questions about the Trinity and
I'm answering is that as I'm answering
these
there's a little voice in my head saying
shut up Jonathan shut up don't talk
about the Trinity don't talk about that
stuff because it doesn't because a lot
of especially the Trinity oh so many of
those words have been so ruined like
they're so ruined you need you there's a
there's a mile you have to walk a mile
before you even get a sense of what
they're talking about I there's a lot of
stuff in Trinitarian theology that I I
trust because I trust the father's and I
trust and I trust that I trust the
church but there's a lot of stuff that I
don't understand like I don't yeah okay
so the Sun the Sun is why am I talking
about again with the Sun is is
engendered and it's like I don't know I
guess it's like I don't totally you know
I I don't completely
that's AII I don't understand at least
rationally I can't talk about it you
know I I can I can talk about a lot of
other stuff but that that particular
thing I'd rather for now at least
I'd rather kind of stay in a let people
get there when they when they get there
and my and the people that are watching
my videos I think I think most of the
people are kind of coming wide-eyed and
now trying to see this you know what is
going on and so I'd rather talk about
Brad let's talk about patterns and
beauty and and how Christ talked about
Christ that's made basically what I talk
about most of the time he's talked about
how how Christ brings everything
together and so yeah that's been that's
been I don't know I can't totally
explain it but I really struggle to I
think I am totally understand when
Jordan I that's why I have so much
sympathy for Jordan when he people ask
him do you believe in God and he's like
I don't want to answer that question
because that question is so loaded and
it's so perverse that if I answer it you
won't understand it because if I just
say yes then then you won't know what
I'm talking about and so so it's I'd
rather not answer it I'll talk about all
this other stuff but then secretly you
know obviously it's like I keep telling
it's obviously Jordan believes in God he
said it in so many ways he just doesn't
want to say it that way because he knows
that especially the people asking to
that date they have ulterior motives
they either want to know if you're on
our side like are you on our side are
you you one of us or are you one of them
are you one of those guys you know and
he's like I don't want to play this game
I'm not interested so so so I
yeah I think I'm kind of also avoiding
that that I'd rather just yeah anyways
sorry enough about that no it was
wonderful that was that that was
fascinating you know your when I was
watching your principalities when you're
going through the principalities and
powers which I really appreciated how
you lined that up
I was really struck where we're talking
about in Judah in Reuben and it's a car
and the I mean the dominant the dominant
the the the Synoptics used kingdom of
heaven John uses eternal life Paul
uses in Christ mm-hmm and you know you
were setting that up with your you know
with your with our internal demons and I
thought that I thought that you know
again pastors a push back on Jordan
Peterson we are liars but we're really
more thieves because you know you were
setting that thing up I gotta steal that
from Jonathan yeah go for it but but you
didn't you know now mentioning you know
you want them to see Christ that's
that's interesting because I I was
listening to you go throughout that but
okay he's just set himself he just
setting us up for in Christ and he
didn't go there know why I well that's
the thing I'm glad I'm revealing my
secrets here that's the thing is that
that the whole manner in which I speak
and I think the whole the whole way I
wish I speak as I is I want most the
time like I want you to kind of say some
things bring you bring you and then
because the problem with and then let
you make the net that next step because
because we've we've sadly we've heard
the name of we've heard preachers go go
at us for too long like not not you
you're good but you know that you know
what I mean is other bad we've heard
them we've come at us for - for too much
and and to just want you to you know
like if you believe in the name of Jesus
you know and all that stuff and and it's
it's come to a point where it doesn't
mean anything anymore
does it mean anything you know believe
in Jesus and you'll be saved I don't
know what you mean by believe not sure
what you mean by Jesus and saved for
sure I don't know what you're talking
about okay so all those things like I
don't know what you're talking about
and so I'd rather talk about bring
people like bring people into them into
that kind of mystery and then let them
see for themselves where it's where it
goes and so I'm that's why I I I'm being
I am always very careful in the way that
I talk about this stuff because yeah
because of that and I and I think it's
it's it's been a lot of it's been ruined
so let's help people understand the
words and in slowly you know I always
tell people I hope that
what I mean my hope and I've said this
in my videos before that my hope is that
one day most people will be able to say
our Father who is in heaven and they
won't have to explain it any more they
won't have to say but for now you need
to understand why we say father you need
to understand why we say heaven you need
to understand all that stuff and at some
point I mean I I do it I can say our
Father was in heaven and not flinch at
all because I I don't I feel like I'm
enough in the story that it's fine but
but that's my hope you know and so I
might that's my hope enduring to is that
he he sets up this whole story about how
you know this this this this bottom-up
structure of how the Father you know
that that we've created
we've kind of all these images of
different fathers have have come
together into this like essential image
of the Father and kind of doing this
bottom-up thing until we realize that
there is this image of the Heavenly
Father and you know it's part of our
it's built in us you know this image and
so now I don't have to say that all that
stuff you don't have to say that anymore
you can just say our Father who is in
heaven Hallowed be your name
did you see what I'm saying it's all
right that's what I want that's what I
want that's kind of my that's what I
think III need to I need to do is to to
talk about those things first and then
we'll get there slowly I mean already
like the stuff about angels and
principalities you know I've been making
these videos for like a year and I've
been wanting to talk about this stuff
for a year and I kept saying no it's not
not yet not yet don't talk about this
and then then the Don Hoffman stuff
started coming on like okay this is the
times coming then Jordan and and Sam had
those discussions and Sam keeps talking
about conscience so at some point I
thought okay now's the time and I can
talk about this stuff because I think
people have enough at least people have
been watching my videos they have enough
foundation that they can hear me say
these things without thinking that I'm
talking about Marvel Comics superheroes
you live in other dimensions when I talk
about angels cuz you go to a church I
even like when I was growing up people
would say stupid things like that they
would say I think angels are beings in
other dimensions I don't
what are you talking about other
dimensions my goodness science fiction
you know it's like in because we have
Scientology and Mormonism and and all
these these these kind of really
disturbing materialistic religions and a
lot of Christians they have that too
they just don't they don't sometimes
it's not any conscious but if they think
that demons are physical beings somehow
heard that angels are physical beings
that they're not they've never been no
one has ever thought they were if you
read the father's they either say that
they're immaterial or they say that they
have subtle bodies it's like okay what
does that mean subtle bodies well I can
tell you I can give you examples of
subtle bodies you know it's like a
story's a subtle body you know they're
all forms of subtle bodies you know a
city is a subtle body because it doesn't
you can't totally contain it like it's
not a it's not completely so you have
you have different levels of bodies
anyways I'm speaking this is becoming a
rant this is a journalist I I feel like
I got a scoop you know Jonathan Perot
and the subtle bodies you know it's it's
interesting to me because you know from
the our last conversation I know a bit
about your story in terms of you know
growing up and angelical and and
listening to you listening to your
description of you know you're going I'm
gonna be careful with my words I'll just
say you're evangelist heart your
pastoral heart you know that that's what
I hear you say you want people to say to
be able to say our Father words in
heaven and and when I hear that you know
I hear Home Coming I hear I hear being
at home in a relationship because to say
you know to say our Father
well that suddenly Orient's you with God
and it Orient's you with your neighbor
because it's not my father
yeah it's our Father who is in heaven
Hallowed be your name thy kingdom come
Thy will be done on earth as it is in
heaven
give us a day I mean off that off off we
go into the prayer so I that really
helps me
that helps me in a whole bunch of levels
because you know for a long time I
pester people because I obviously live
within a Protestant tradition and in in
a diverse context where I'll have people
coming from lots of different traditions
often african-american churches and
they'll just draw words like saved and
then if I'm in a sunday-school class
I'll usually stop them and I'll ask well
what do you mean by that
and it becomes very clear they don't
have any idea what their meaning by that
or it's simply code talk for hell
avoidance when when you die and and then
as a pastor okay now I'm gonna start to
poke around at these things and and do a
little because I and to gently begin to
have use you know that's what pastors do
so it's very interesting for me you're
not going to sit here and make all these
videos if you know okay you've got
patreon and this is open new
opportunities for you but you as well as
I this isn't gonna make you either of us
rich and so what you are doing what you
are what you are doing is coming out of
your heart and it's coming out of it's
coming out of the joy the joy that you
found it you know and this isn't
uniquely Christian I mean what Sam
Harris is doing I was just listening to
you talk I I listened to the first about
a half hour of the first vancouver talk
where Peterson and and and Harris are
kind of getting a lay of the land
I mean Sam Harris very much means well
he he wants when you listen to him when
you listen to his heart's desire he
wants in his own words well-being for
people he doesn't want to see people
hampered by what he calls superstition
and so he's got a plan for how this can
be and this is the this is the mission
that he's pursuing I have a mission you
have a mission and it was it was helpful
for me to hear I thought you were just
very transparent now I'm sure you're
gonna take some shots for a variety of
things that you said from certain
corners of the church and I expect that
but you're a big boy you can take it but
it was helpful for me to hear your heart
and to and to understand because you and
a
you very much helped me see you and
understand you know what's going on with
you and what's going on with your videos
and you know I might I might I think if
if we we could probably spend a long
time talking about angels and demons
because you know I think I've probably
I'm not quite sure I haven't quite fully
digested what I know where you're going
with this and how I feel about it but it
was it was very very interesting I don't
think people will find it quite
interesting so well interesting i think
i think that that i think for me if you
altima tea
it's to help ivy it's ultimately to help
people see how beautiful you know our
tradition is how just how coherent and
beautiful it is not in a scientific
sense but almost like this almost like
this powerful beautiful artwork like
this this this this poem that has been
that has laid itself out in the Bible
and then also then in the liturgy and in
and in in art and in architecture all
these things it's just how how how
beautiful is and what it points to
obviously but but uh but yeah my I know
that my but I know that most of people
that listen to me it they're not they're
not Chris yeah I'm not talking to most
of the most people I'm talking to or not
let's say that that that person that
comes to church and maybe doesn't have a
lot of education that talks about heaven
and talks about being saved and going to
heaven and a very kind of naive and and
misunderstood way um it's funny because
this is where a Samaras would really be
angry with me but but that person
doesn't bother me much he doesn't really
bother me because even though their
understanding might be a bit off might
be a bit I might be a bit naive and a
bit kind of simplistic and and and some
kind of even offensive even sometimes
they're on the path and that structure
is doing for them what it needs to do
ready it's still doing even though they
don't have the most profound
understanding of what these words mean
the pattern that they're in that they're
on the path that they're on is still
doing the work that it's doing you know
and and the grace of God is acting in
that person's life and so I'm not
talking to those people so when I'm who
I'm talking to her for people who are
usually very intelligent who have gone
through college who who have studied who
have read who have studied and so they
they look at these words and they they
don't understand they can't see a more
profound meaning to them they can't
understand how profound these structures
are and how deep they are and so those
are the people I'm talking to and I want
to help them to see what's what's going
on so that at their level of of
intelligence of knowledge of study they
can perceive at least what this is about
because they're not going to go for the
for the the when I die I'm going to
heaven bit they're just not going to go
for it because it's it's not it's not
enough you know it's it's too it's too
it's it's kind of naive and too
simplistic and so they need more and and
I think that I think that that's why
people are being so attracted to Doron
Peterson is because they feel like he's
giving them more that he's giving them
some some meat something that helps them
to understand what what is going on in
these stories and in in our in our
tradition that means laid aside and so
and also yeah too because and and then
then what what that does is it it helps
also these new atheist types to to
understand that their vision their
understanding of Christianity is at that
level right it's at my it's like my
aunts my aunt's kuku who dropped out of
school and you know in the ninth grade
or whatever that's at the level that
their that their understanding is and in
a way I I keep saying did that aunt is
fine she's totally fine but if you think
that that's where it stops and then
you're the problems not her because she
doesn't have the capacity to understand
anymore and that's totally fine because
human beings have different capacity and
that person can be way more virtuous way
more full of grace and full of trust you
know in in in the infinite than you do
even though they don't totally
understand these concepts but I get but
I can understand that at your level you
need to you need something that you can
that you can hold on to and grip on do
to understand what this is talking about
so that's I think that that's really
been
that's been what I'm doing that's who
I'm talking to and that's why you know
people invite me to do talks it's at
universities it's it's always in places
where I'm talking to that crowd so yeah
hopefully it does what Oakley it has a
little effect I hope no it's having an
effect because you know I hear that and
people who write me and they appreciate
what you have to say and I think of CS
Lewis's you know what it praises inner
inner health made audible and I think
you're you're doing art and and what
you've just expressed you are there's a
joy in you and you want to share it
what's what's more what's better than
that
I mean that that's the best way to spend
a life there's you've been you've been
given gifts you've been given joy and
what are you doing you're carving or
doing your videos you're you're sharing
the joy that you have within within the
frame of reference and and within what
you've learned in order in order to
share that and it's it's attract with a
particular audience so I've been doing
most of the interviewing I don't know if
yeah what happened I heard you kind of
on the turn there but thanks thanks for
that ball I appreciate it I appreciate
your your kind words all right no and I
you know we this what we're doing on
this YouTube is a new thing and Petersen
says this often and I think he's dead on
right we have no idea what we're doing
with this thing we don't know the
ramifications we don't know where this
leads the the you know the opportunities
that this has made for each of us are
unique and there it is it is it is
important to ask ourselves why because
when I look in my heart well there's
some there's some noble reasons to do
this and there's a bunch of really
crappy ones too
I'm sure yeah that's for sure that's
certain and and these you know these
this feeds this feeds some of the better
angels of my nature and this feed some
of the darker demons of my nature and so
it's it's so we watch each other and I
watch you do this and
and so part of me wants to know what
makes Jonathan dick why are you doing
this you're you're an icon carver and
you're making videos and you're you're
trying to explain
do your best to explain why Santa Claus
is real well this is an interesting
thing and you're hoping to do this for
you're hoping to do this so that others
can share in the joy that you found and
you I mean the journey that you've had
in terms of your your church journey has
been you know I think you said it very
clearly whenever did you say I want I
want them to be able to pray our Father
was in heaven and I think that for me
you know that drew a picture of of a
pilgrim who has come home of a of a son
who has been restored to the father of a
son who's been restored to the family I
think about Luke 15 and you know how the
parable of the prodigal son and so I
I've always seen your work as that as
that of an evangelist and I think
ironically this is another debate we had
last night at the meetup is Peterson's
you know someone asked his Peterson an
apologist and I thought no he's not an
apologist like I see a lot of Protestant
yeah Paolo Jetix being done but he is in
many ways an evangelist he's he's in you
know you call him Cyrus I've kind of
been working to John the Baptist thing
with him because there's a certain
resonance between John's message and you
know hey Roman soldiers pitcher you know
sort out your relationship with the
hierarchy but yeah so I don't know I
think it's I think it's cool and I love
to hear I poke at you because I and I'm
really happy I did because I heard your
heart and it's a beautiful thing
so I appreciate that yeah but like like
you said to her and I think that we
struggle I mean I struggle like you said
we do this and then and then like we get
attention like I'm getting attention for
these videos and I'm getting people
writing me and everything and so you
know to keeping that ego down has been
it's been oh my goodness that's really
tough I have a I have a definitely I'm
quite an arrogance I have a very strong
streak of arrogance I'm really trying to
hold that back as it
sometimes it comes out you know oh my
goodness Jonathan take it down a notch
so yeah so confession has been good for
me in terms of that pride thing in the
end and the attention
hopefully that God will kind of keep me
you know on the level and won't have to
knock me down at some point if I get too
cocky so try to keep it at a keep keep
it at the right level anything out
anything else you want to go over today
or you think we've no I think I think I
I mean I've really I ended up speaking
most of the time so uh yeah well so so
yeah thanks for I think we've actually
also gone for like an hour and a half
which is probably should we should
definitely do the next time then I'll
interview you will just kind of well
trade off you interview me I'll
interview you like one or the other and
so and hopefully I'll come to see you at
some point I yeah I'd like to I'd like
to I'd like to do a conference at some
point and fly you out here and I think
that would be I think that would be a
lot of fun there's some maybe the the
impact of the the Eastern Church has
been a late comer to the American
conversation and America has been this
in this melting pot and it's become a
neutral space in which different church
traditions can communicate and so at one
of one of my friends and colleagues in a
neighbor and a sister church up the road
has a as a very deep relationship with
with an Orthodox priest and so he's
often bringing him into our circles and
and I thought boy it'd be fun to have
Jonathan out here and he hadn't heard of
you so don't your head should be that
big but he hadn't heard of it baby and
the Orthodox so one of the guys from my
meetup is moving to Dallas and he says
he I found a Jordan Peterson meet up
there and it's run by an Orthodox father
and and I thought hilarious well this
will be an interesting meet up when you
get there send me some reports but you
don't want to know what those Jordan
Peterson meetups look like so that's
funny but yeah I mean God is doing you
know God is doing a work that obviously
again as a Calvinist you know what does
God
- I don't know but as in the words of
Freddy Schuler God is large and in
charge and I'm sure things are things
are moving and so so that is that is for
certain and I think that that people
people people should pay attention for I
think it's great that you're around
paying attention and also kind of
helping others to to understand that we
it's best that we not ignore what's
happening because there's definitely
something going on and so we need to to
be attentive and to speak into it as
much as we as we can so so yeah so
thanks for doing what you're doing well
thank you Jonathan and now uh yeah I'll
just stop the recording now